when we last spoke to him free agents he
was approaching now free agency done and
the draft is done and rick spielman
is done with the bulk of his work at
least for now but it's on to 2022 and
it's rick spielman rick welcome back how
are you pal welcome thanks for having me
on today what do you do
when the draft is over what's your work
day become
well it's right now i've got uh some
finished some coaches contracts i got
the whole flip operation staff from a
country
finishing their contracts um
i got you know doing some things on the
business side uh you know
overseeing some guys that we have to
bring in
right now for our rookie mini camp so
there's just a hundred things that are
going on still and it never seems to
really end you just
shift your focus from the draft and free
agency now you shift it over to more
administrative things that you have to
get done of course the rookie mini camp
coming up in a couple of weeks it's the
first time you have players back in the
building i saw somewhere that the teams
are limited to five tryout players but
it's still a healthy compliment of of
players who will be there for a few days
on the field practicing right yeah it
depends by each team on how many college
free agents how many draft picks
um also if there's some teams from your
or some players from your current roster
that are still eligible to participate
in this that varies from team to team as
well i think we won't in the past we've
always had about 60 guys out there
because we had maybe 40 of them 30 of
them that has opened tryouts and that's
how we would find an adam thielen or
cj hamm or marcus cheryl's types um we
found chad bibi down out of one of those
camps unfortunately this year we can't
do it but the fortunate part is at least
our coaches can get on the grass with
these guys start teaching them technique
uh especially with the the all the draft
picks coming in and the college for
agents coming in where last year all we
did was zoom with them and you know our
players our rookies didn't even know
where the uh facility was until the
first day they showed up at training
camp so hopefully this will help
expedite their uh process and and and
get our coaches start working with these
guys you know i think back to how crazy
last year was and the vikings one of the
teams that had very few if any fans at
any point during the season really took
away that great home field advantage
what's the current anticipation of how
many fans you think you'll have when
september rolls around well we'll just
wait you know that's not our decision
it'll be you know with the
andrew miller our co working with the
government i know uh the twins and the
wild uh are letting certain amount of
fans in right now
um so we'll see what happens as it goes
i know the timberwolves have some people
down there but hopefully it'll continue
as people get vaccinated
and this covet comes under control a
little bit more that we'll be able to
have close to hopefully full capacity or
at least have fans in there and the
other thing i think is important is is
having fans here at training camp
because that gets everybody's juices
flowing from the players from the
coaches and even the fans being able to
participate and come out and watch uh
training camp but that's to be
determined
until then the draft gets a lot of fans
juices flowing and let's pivot to that
let me start with just very basically i
see grades starting to pop up in the
media
do you do you give a grade
to your own draft and if so what grade
would you give this year's
i'm not that uh i'm not smart enough to
put a grade on these guys i know how we
feel about them but it's like until we
get out there and see them and
you know there's guys that surprise you
that how quickly they're going to make
an impact on this roster other guys it
may take some time to develop but you
don't know that until we actually get
going and and i never put a grade as as
the kind of golden rule out there to see
where there are three years from now you
know guys can have
some ups and downs for the first couple
years and all sudden that something
sticks and they and they play well um
but i i just like you said i'm not smart
enough as some of those uh draft uh
pundits out there i guess would be the
term like yourself that can put grades
on me hey hey rick i give the same
grades every year everybody gets an
incomplete
reason to just explain because we don't
know we don't know and it would be
foolish to know hey do you think that
we're getting any closer
to the point where
you can tell you still can't all the
time all the money all the analytics
everything you put into it you still
don't know until you put the guy out on
the field with other nfl caliber players
right right and some of these guys you
know you haven't seen in over a year
playing competitive football some of the
guys that had opted out you know some of
the guys we were able to see a little
bit uh while they got a chance to
practice down at the senior bowl but
some of these guys the only thing we had
to go off of what they did at their pro
day uh and that's basically doing drills
that are in the non-competitive
situations and that's why what jim nagy
was able to pull off down there at the
senior bowl and to see these guys in
that atmosphere and setting was probably
the last realistic look that we got at
the guys that were at the senior bowl
uh as far as what they're going to be
potentially as football players
take me through
how the mechanics go when you're on the
clock at 14
and the jets trade up and you trade down
did you know before the draft even began
that it was a possibility the jets were
going to give you a phone call and make
you an offer in that 10-minute window no
usually where we were picking and
hopefully we're not picking that high
again
because everybody's going to see
how the board's falling and what what
players are potentially going to be
there not be there it's hard to predict
after the first two picks who else is
going to be there so
most of the time in my experience and
almost all the time it's when you're on
the clock is when you're getting the
calls or maybe a pick or two before
so there's a lot of communication going
on that no at one point
we have three teams on the on the phone
at the same time and everybody's
throwing out different ideas and
different scenarios uh we have an
automated system where i can see
everything going on and whether hey
let's just stick and take the player or
this trades better than this trade and
that can be i know when we had that
scenario this draft there was two
minutes left on the clock
um that a particular team was uh trying
to trade up with us
and even though you weren't there when
it happened i'm sure that's the last
thing
that the vikings want to be attached to
is the clock running out again even
though it was 18 years ago when it
occurred and it ended up being a pretty
good player so
true
but no
you want to be prepared and you just
have to make uh a lot of split second
decisions and just say tell them no
we're just going to take our player or
yeah let's do that trade you know last
year we were very active trading uh you
know accumulated i think up 15 picks
this year uh we only traded once the
whole time uh in the first round and
then we were able to accumulate so many
picks in those middle rounds the third
and fourth round uh that we felt there
were a lot of good players there that we
wanted to take to come in and help our
ball club
didn't feel the draft was as deep in the
later rounds and college free agency so
that's why we kind of stuck to let's get
our best players and the best players
available in that middle round last year
there were a lot more players available
and we actually
uh accumulated all those seventh round
picks and i my philosophy there whether
right or wrong was that's going to be
our college for agency because i don't
know how this virtual
signing players after the draft
virtually is going to work so
the the strategic thinking that goes in
every year depends on the depth of the
board the amount of players on the board
and is is how you kind of formulate what
you're going to do
what do you use to determine that you're
getting the right value when you go from
14 to 23. i mean the bears had to give
up next year's first round or to go from
20 to 11 and i know it's a different
dynamic
but still
how do you get it just right that you
know it's fair for you
and it's fair for the jets and we're
gonna go ahead and pull the trigger and
call this
a trade that balances out with you
picking up two threes
then picking up a fourth rounder and
you're flip-flopping 14 and 23.
uh a lot of it is everybody has their
trade charts you know but
we try to to really look at historical
value of trades uh rob brzezinski and
our analytics team that do a great job
on the value and what historically has
been given for that pick
the other thing we've really honed in in
on is looking at different buckets so if
you do trade um and you trade out of
let's say pick one through seven as the
same exact player when they become pros
and
pick number 16 through 40 is the exact
same success rate when they become pros
so we kind of work in buckets as we do
all of our training as we go through the
draft and not trying to trade down too
far into a separate bucket
uh so there's a lot of different things
that's really evolved since you know the
first trade chart had come out the point
system would come out and so we're doing
a lot of things based on historical
value and how our analytics have come up
with the buckets that we want to be in
i know that a lot of cards get held
close to the vest before during and
after the draft but did you get it 23
and christian darasaw the guy you would
have taken at 14 if you hadn't done a
trade i will say we were very excited to
get christian darasol
and all that that implies or doesn't
imply
let me fast forward to your next pick in
round three because you didn't have a
second round or as a result of the
yannick way trade but you picked up a
third rounder when you traded yannick
and gaque to the ravens calendar
first first i have a i have a trivia
question for you okay
the vikings have drafted 26 quarterbacks
since the team
launched in 1961.
when is the last time the vikings used a
third round draft pick on a quarterback
uh
not during my time not during the last
16 years i know that for a fact
calamond is the first third round
vikings quarterback since the first
vikings draft when fran tarkenton was a
third round pick out of georgia so big
shoes already for kalimond to phil the
first third rounder since then what
attracted he's getting that down right
now
from mike florio today that's the first
time that's ever happened what attracted
you to kellen monde you know we spent a
lot of time uh on on the quarterbacks
this year and the one thing that kellen
really it really stuck out to us on his
progression from
his rookie year uh to what he did his
second year and then this year i know
you know seeing him performing that
florida game you know off the tape and
how he won a close game then he goes
down and wins a big game
in the bowl game against north carolina
who had a lot of great players on that
roster who got drafted this past weekend
and then you go down to the senior bowl
and as a first chance we get to see him
live
and see how he
kept ascending through this process and
how well he played down at the senior
bowl we sent our coaches down to his pro
day andrew janoko our quarterback coach
really liked his workout uh in fact i
spent
thursday night and friday uh watching
his hour zoom call again uh with our
coaches
and going through
getting to know the kid because a lot of
times this year for me personally
i didn't get to talk to a lot of these
kids because the month of march i was
traveling so much trying to get to as
many pro days but our coaches and our
scouts and working together i think we
did over 200 zoom calls this year and we
recorded them all so i can go back when
i got off the road or this time or when
i had time in the evening to sit there
and listen to these zoom calls to get to
know these kids
um you know because
we i never had an interaction with him
except when i was down at the
senior bowl but his interview was very
impressive and our coaches think there
are things that he needs to get
corrected but they're all correctable
with coaching and he has some really
natural athletic skills he can throw on
the run and he's a great scheme fit here
for what we're trying to do
when you said you did a lot of work on
the quarterbacks this year are you
talking about the cut that second cut
beyond the top five are you talking
about all of them up to and including
the guys taken at the very top of the
draft well i i can tell you it's not
just quarterbacks we do that with every
position so uh because you never know
what happens in the draft so we try to
put just as much time on the top of the
board as we do in the later rounds and
the processes that we put in place the
amount of meetings the the uh when the
coaches get involved and doing two
different coaching meetings with them um
you know so
i'm not going to say we put we put a lot
of time in every year not only on
quarterbacks but we've done that every
year since i've been here i think it's
important that you have to do your work
and your homework because you never know
what's going to happen
and plus you don't know what's going to
happen down the road so if there's a
trade or you sign a guy or a guy gets
cut you already have all that
information information built into your
system because you did the work uh when
they were coming out of college
i watched your press conference on
saturday after the mond selection friday
night rather
and you said that
you had him
right up there among the top
quarterbacks where did he rank chris
sims was one of the few that had him at
number four ahead of justin fields and
trey lance where did he fall on your
ranking of the quarterbacks in this
draft well i'm sorry i didn't invite you
mike to see our draft board in the
rankings at the position
but we felt uh you know where we got him
uh that we were very excited to get him
actually i i i was just going to show up
i was just going to knock on the door
and say you know let me in when you
passed your proven tests and mesa tests
and you were vaccinated you could have
potential access fully and completely
vaccinated baby just like you i saw your
sticker on your lapel this weekend
the mond pick at round three you know
when you take quarterback round one
sends a message round two sends a
message round seven different message
round three
as a vikings fan who would be looking at
this trying to process
what does this mean
what does it mean what would be your
message to the average vikings fan about
what they should take from the fact that
this third round pick was devoted on a
quarterback that the team and the
organization think highly of
one we're following our board so he was
the best player available at that time
on our draft board regardless of
position
two i know we wanted kirk's our
quarterback and we wanted to
create competition uh with all our young
quarterbacks with nate stanley with jake
browning and now with kellen monde
to have those guys all come in and
compete and just see where it takes us
would you consider trading up into round
two to get monde
i'm not going to say what we considered
it might have been mining it might have
been 16 other players that we could
consider trading up you're always i just
tell you we've been very
from a philosophical standpoint we're
always very proactive on trying to move
up and down
uh that draft board regardless of who
the player is i spoke to kirk cousins
super bowl week and he told me he wants
to retire as a member of the vikings but
he also made it clear that he feels no
compulsion to extend a contract that
runs through 2022 has a huge cap number
next year and as a practical matter
because he was tagged twice by
washington he can't be franchise tagged
in 2023 so he's got a lot of leverage
there how much of this choice
was aimed at protecting yourself against
the possibility that cousins has two
really strong years
and
commands top dollar and walks away in
free agency you know
you're always kind of looking at your
roster and where it may be two or three
years down the road but that's hard to
predict as much as you tried a roster
plan so
you know every rookie that we we draft
we're hoping that regardless of position
that they're going to be here and
whatever role they end up carving out
they end up
helping the minnesota vikings whether it
be in a backup role starter role special
teams roles so
we're just trying to put the best 53
players together and trying to bring in
young competition every year to compete
with the guys that are currently on our
roster
and you're always looking down the road
but you don't know that until you get
everything in the building and start
working with these guys and let's just
see where we're at down the road
you said the other night that you didn't
contact kirk cousins before the pick was
made that that's not something that you
ordinarily would do have you spoken to
him since the pick was made of calendar
oh yeah no i spoke to him saturday
morning him and
talk to his agent and just say just let
him know that we want to make sure we
have competition behind him that kirk's
there's no doubt kirk's our quarterback
going forward and that uh you know we
want to create competition to see who's
going to be the backup
and uh no kirk was great he understands
and he you know he knows he's our guy
his agent knows he's our guy so
right now we're just focusing on
getting ready for this season coming up
give me a quick assessment of where you
think the defensive line is post draft
given that last year especially with
danielle hunter injured it seemed to
fall off yannick and gawkway didn't work
out you retraded him as i mentioned
earlier where's the pass rush and the
defensive line right now we think we
were able to definitely upgrade our
defensive line uh we were pretty
proactive in free agency
uh you know signing stephen weatherly
back but knowing the depth of probably
this defensive tackle market
uh you know that's why the tomlinson
signing was so important for us and to
get a michael pierce back uh to get some
of these young pass rushers along with
dj wanham who we think has tremendous
upside and ada robinson and patrick
jones uh we think there's going to be
great competition there and it's
definitely going to help our pass rush
and when you can improve your pass rush
it sure does help the back end uh with
the secondary where do things stand
right now with danielle hunter missed
all last year after next surgery every
once in a while there's a flare up as it
relates to his contract what's your
expectation for him in 2021 i think he's
going to have an excellent outstanding
year for us so looking forward to
getting him back on the field along with
all the other guys that we weren't able
to to play with last year and i think
getting all that gang back together
along with the new additions and free
agency and the picks that we had in the
draft uh very excited to see where this
team is headed
last one for you and i hate to say that
because usually that means there's
another one after that
but
as it relates to the aaron rodgers
situation in green bay i'm curious from
your perspective when something like
this goes down between a player and a
team whether it's him and the packers
desean watson and the texans how closely
do you pay attention to how it gets
handled how the players involved the
agents involved handle it just for your
own edification
if and when you find yourself in a
similar predicament you study how those
teams handle it because that may or may
not influence you on how to handle a
situation like that well the first site
i go to is pro football talk
[Laughter]
read everything we say about it and then
do the opposite
[Laughter]
no i i really you know you always read
things and stuff like that and but you
know aaron rodgers is maybe the best
quarterback that ever played this game
and and you know i'm never going to talk
about anyone else's players one i'm not
allowed to it's illegal
um but you just always look at different
situations always you know the most
important thing is evaluating us and our
decisions and if we do make mistakes how
do we correct them or what would we do
differently and if something works out
great what do we do well so we continue
to do that so my main focus is here on
the minnesota vikings i remember last
year they asked coach mike zimmer about
the packers trading up to get jordan
love and he said i hope they trade aaron
rodgers i think that's what they should
do i have a feeling zimmer would say the
same thing right now if you were to talk
about it rick it's great as always
talking to you congratulations on
getting through another draft and all
the best as you get the guys ready for
the 2021 season which is always we'll be
here before we know it i appreciate you
having me on it's always fun to come on
with you mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports